this next scene is called more than new
paint in this very early version the
scene sterling is the one that saw crews
for what she's capable of that's not the
way we wanted to ultimately go with the
story that was just a wrong turn on our
part you know we wanted to create a
story where it was all about the Queen
and Cruise's relationship and McQueen is
the one that saw her value and when
nobody else would
when she didn't even see it in herself
she's just a trainer know she's a racer
just took me a while to see it and the
story evolves from standing on the
shoulders of all these previous versions
wait what
what'd you say I'm not letting you race
what do you well we had a deal it's the
best thing for you
don't you realize who you are the
biggest brand racing has ever seen brand
I'm not a brand are you kidding the
second you retire you'll be worth two
three times what you could make on the
track oil tires all kinds of
endorsements as a fan I want all of this
for you hires oil we had a deal we did
but then your numbers started coming
back from your trip whoa numbers your
suit I was tracking your speed your
agility on the beach on the road during
the demolition derby and then we noticed
how your numbers compared with cruise
cruise she was wearing one of those
suits as well and lightening the numbers
she was putting up every day when she
was raising you well I have never seen
anything like it and she got better by
the day he or she was out there to train
you and really you were training her she
was learning from the great lightning
McQueen I should be thanking you you can
now move much quicker into Phase two of
your career and I can race her I'd be a
fool not to
Hey what are you doing stuck Hey Oh you
can't do that I'm sorry I knew how much
you'd want to race today I took your
name off the 95 license I can only race
one car now
go home get some rest you'll feel better
about things in a few days
[Music]